الفرعون المصري توت عنخ امون مات تحت
تاثير الكحول فرديه جديده تثير جدلا واسعا
حول لغز موت الملك الفرعوني الشاب
عالمه المصريات الطبيه الحيويه صوفيا عزيز
كشفت لمجله بيبي
حديث تعرض له اثناء قيادته لعربه بسرعه
كبيره بينما كان تحت تاثير الكحول عزيز
رجحت اصابه تتعنخمون بكسور خطيره في الساق
تسببت لاحقا بعدوى ثم وفاته وهو في سن 19
عاما اختلفت الروايات حول موت توت عنخ
امون بعضها رجح انه كان مريضا بالملاريا
وابحاث اخرى زعمت ان الملك الشاب كان
بحاجه الى عصا للمشي في اشاره الى انه كان
يعاني من اعاقه في قدمه الا ان العالمه
المصريه نفت كل هذه النظريات قائله الى
الممتلكات الموجوده في قبره والتي تنوعت
بين عربات ودروع ومخبئ نبيذ تثبت صحه
فرضتها